[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue dans le 7-8
sport l'émission consacrée à l'actualité
sportive dans le département tout de
suite le sommaire de votre magazine
paris nice la première étape de la 75e
course du soleil et est organisée ce
dimanche à bois d'arcy des milliers de
spectateurs sont venus assister à la
compétition
ils ont pu voir la victoire du français
arnaud démare le résumé dans ce magazine
badminton les volants d'elancourt ont
organisé ce week-end leur traditionnel
tournoi de doubles plus de 350 badistes
ont répondu présent pour cette 16e
édition parmi eux l'un des meilleurs
joueurs du club et en courtois nicolas
complot plus de détails à suivre
automobile l'illinois où liam bertrand
va disputer en 2010 est tout nouveau
championnat de france juniors organisée
par la fédération française de sport
automobile
cette compétition permettra de détecter
les futurs champions de l'hexagone nous
lui avons posé trois questions
gros plan présent sur les principaux
résultats du week-end dans le
département
[Musique]
on commence par du paris-nice la
deuxième étape était organisée
aujourd'hui pour la première fois à
rochefort en yvelines commune de 900
habitants des 170 coureurs encore
présents sont partis sous la pluie pour
un périple de 195 km pour rejoindre la
commune d'amilly près de montargis on
écoute les réactions des spectateurs
juste avant le départ mais je suis très
content qu'il ya cette manifestation à
rochefort ça fait de l'animation 1
c'est assez calme comme petit village
habituellement à bas tous ces nouveaux
d'entraînement nous ici donc vous pensez
bien
on est chez nous en plus on a eu une
magnifique et tapis hier un parcours
magnifique une belle course ont pu soyez
comme quoi des fois pour faire des
belles courses suffit pas avoir d'un des
grands boulevards et autres l'epide
route un peu de vallonné un petit peu de
virages du vent et la pluie tout ça y
est
l'étape s'est terminée à 16h30 pc et
6h30 et si l'italien sony à colbrelli ch
qui s'est imposé au sprint sur cette
deuxième étape
or le démarque prend lui la troisième
place et reste leader du classement
nous allons à présent revenir sur la
première étape du paris nice qui s'est
déroulé elle aussi dans les yvelines
cette année le ces bois d'arcy qui a été
désigné comme village départ pour
l'étape de 148 kilomètres pour ouvrir le
bal sur cette course du soleil avec du
spectacle
les images sont signés à nicolas bombay
du spectacle et de nombreux
rebondissements pour cette première
étape à bois d'arcy la course du soleil
n'en avait que le nom
les 22 équipes cyclistes ont dû
affronter ce dimanche 5 mars les
bourrasques de vent la pluie le
redoutable parcours de 148 km 500
concocté par les organisateurs
dans la vallée de chevreuse et dans le
secteur de plaisir quelques heures avant
le départ les coureurs étaient pourtant
confiant sur le déroulement de la
compétition
moi je suis presque à la maison en plus
on n'est pas loin de saint quentin en
yvelines mais j'ai passé des bons
moments à 50 ans
sur le vélodrome et non c'est beaucoup
de motivation mais bon aussi un petit
peu de pression on est pressé dès le
départ le départ justement des milliers
de spectateurs avaient répondu présent
pour pousser les 170 cycliste malgré un
temps pluvieux dans le public de bois
d'arcy des novices mais également des
experts donc on n'est pas tellement les
équipes nous on en vient boire juste le
spectacle quand on est là pour la les
voir les performances
je constate qu'il y en a quatre qui sont
partis devant le peloton et avait l'air
vachement a l'air plutôt et irait donc
ça veut dire qu'il a dû y avoir soit des
chutes soit plusieurs attaques
c'est surprenant pour un porte pour
aussi facile ne m'a en tout cas dits
faciles avec peu de difficultés sur le
bitume le sprinteur de la fdj arnaud
démare 25 ans remporte finalement la
course au bout du suspense dans les
derniers mètres en devançant son
compatriote alaphilippe ça a été une
étape absolument magnifique peut-être la
plus belle étape de paris-nice plus
belle première étape de paris nice
depuis 20 ans 25 ans avec une bagarre
incroyable avec les conditions
atmosphériques bien sûr qu'ils ont
beaucoup joué
l'appui notamment le vent mais ça a été
quasiment comme une étape de montagne
sauf qu'elle a été remportée par un
sprinteur l'un des meilleurs sprinteurs
du peloton arnaud démare l'ancien
champion de france le vainqueur de milan
san remo l'année dernière un bonheur que
certains ont voulu prolonger en allant à
la rencontre des coureurs après la
course je regarde le matériel je regarde
les coureurs je discute également avec
les personnes qui sont des passionnés
comme moi autour des camions je
regardais mécanicien puis aussi j'essaye
de voir quelques coureurs qui passe
furtivement de du büso à l'hôtel
rendez vous l'année prochaine dans les
yvelines le département accueillera la
course du soleil pendant au minimum
quatre éditions
un mot de handball à présent c'est
peut-être l'un des meilleurs matches de
la saison de l'équipe féminine year fait
mine de l'ess montillot bretonneux à
l'occasion de la 13e journée de
nationale 2 les i montaigne se sont
imposés 2 10 buts devant leur public
contre le leader du classement brest
le score est sans appel 31 à 21 en
écoute le président du club christophe
reding était évidemment ravi de cette
performance
pour nous c'était ça a été fabuleux ça a
été fabuleux parce qu'en fait on
commence à trouver de la constance en a
en fait des résultats suite au suite aux
entraînements et maintenant 1 à la
différence de ce qui se passait en fait
en début de saison on commence à mettre
des buts c'est le franchement leur plus
beau match
oui effectivement soit plus beau match
aussi bien dans l'intensité qu'elles ont
pu mettre dans la constance durant la
totalité de la durée du match
football américain deuxième défaite
consécutive pour les templiers
d'elancourt en deuxième division les
hommes de frédéric anderson se sont
inclinés à l'extérieur sur le terrain
des spartiates d'amiens sur le score de
38 à 12 le bilan 10 ans courtois reste
tout de même positif avec trois
victoires pour deux contre-performances
les gens restent donc en course pour
remonter en fin de saison l'écoutent le
directeur sportif des templiers
d'elancourt fans avec un des ressorts
nous reste cinq matches on a la moitié
de la saison donc on va faire le point
avec les avec les autres coaches pensent
qu'on peut régler est ce qu'on peut
améliorer comment comment aider les
joueurs à continuer de progresser et
s'en sortir normalement on devrait
pouvoir espérer ressortir une même fiche
sur la moitié de saison et est accroché
une place en play-offs à partir de ce
moment là ce sera ma shy'm à élimination
directe donc c'est une autre saison qui
commence
on continue par du rugby la 14e journée
du championnat de fédérale 3 et peut
être un tournant dans la saison 2
plaisir joueurs du coach jean miss se
sont imposés contre on y est dans le
même temps ris orangis a perdu sur le
terrain de mots conséquence les plaisirs
hoa prennent la tête du classement
devant ris orangis et peuvent espérer
terminer premier de la poule
une fois n'est pas coutume nous allons
parler de badminton dans ce magazine le
club des volants d'elancourt organisé ce
week end son traditionnel tournoi de
double plus de 350 badistes ont répondu
présent pour cette 16e édition
parmi eux l'un des meilleurs joueurs du
club élan pour toi à nicolas mon plots
avantage 2
j'adore les dents pour toi nicolas
montpeloux 30 ans pratique le badminton
depuis ses 10 ans et 106 au club des
volontaires en cours depuis 2012 il a
décidé de participer ce samedi 4 mars à
la 16e édition du tournoi du club au
palais des sports en présence de 350
autres joueurs venus principalement
d'île de france
je ne recherche plus tôt de m'amuser je
fais pas les deux tours impartialement
les gagner mais vraiment passé une bonne
ambiance
alors avec avec le club ce soit ici ou
même dans les autres tournois c'est
vraiment de s'amuser
voilà ces tournois de milieu de saison
on arrive au mois de mars
il nous reste quatre mois à faire au
niveau compétition derrière jusqu'au
mois de juin aujourd'hui nicolas s'est
inscrit en double la formule du tournoi
le sportif s'est associé à accepter a
dit un autre joueur du club âgé de 34
ans leur objectif remporter la victoire
dans leur catégorie r4 on a une relation
plutôt complémentaires sachant que
nicolas et il tape il tape très fort et
moi je suis plus un joueur qui est
qu'ils posent et qui sait servir
premier match et première victoire de la
journée pour les deux élans courtois le
score est sans appel le 21 12 et 21 11
dans le deuxième set
christian une contraction au début de
match mais s'est vite ça s'est vite
dissipée voilà on a pu mettre notre jeu
en place on est on est on est prêt pour
le deuxième match de poule le parcours
de ce duo s'est finalement arrêté en
demi finale dans la catégorie r4 ils
reviendront sans aucun doute l'année
prochaine en mars 2018 pour tenter
d'accrocher cette fois ci la victoire
une page aviron dans ce magazine la
fédération internationale a décidé de
supprimer début février le quatre sans
barreur poids léger des jeux olympiques
à coup dur pour le versailles et à
thomas baruch médaillé de bronze aux
derniers jo dans cette catégorie qui
compte quatre sportifs à bord du bateau
nous avons pu le rencontrer du côté du
cercle nautique de versailles sur le
grand canal du château alors je suis
avec thomas baruch médaille de bronze
aux derniers jeux olympiques de rio où
l'été dernier alors thomas barrau qui
n'est pas forcément de très bonne humeur
aujourd'hui ce matin puisque sa
catégorie le quatre sans barreur poids
léger vient tout simplement de
disparaître du programme olympique une
décision de la fédération internationale
alors thomas baruch vous dans quel
sentiment vous avez suite à cette
annonce
je suis pas surpris 1 c'est des
discussions qui ont lieu depuis deux ans
maintenant
je me suis un petit peu investi pour
essayer de défendre ma catégorie de
faire alors quelques arguments on avait
bien senti que
ça avait du mal à convaincre et qu'il y
avait beaucoup de poids en face de la
part de la fédération internationale et
d'autres institutions qui disait que
j'étais assez peu positif sur l'issue du
vote
déçu forcément et puis surtout
maintenant il va falloir se lancer dans
un nouveau défi puisque avec mon
coéquipier timoko l'orne a décidé de
changer de catégorie et de passer en
pointe toutes catégories justement donc
on va se retrouver contre des
adversaires qui auront quelques
centimètres et quelques fioles puisque
nous et est ce que c'est une décision
logique peut-être qu'il y avait moi
licenciés peut-être dans cette catégorie
où peut-être moins de pratiquants de mon
point de vue non elle n'est absolument
pas logique puisque l'aviron poids
légers a été développé pour ouvrir notre
sport justement à des nations qui n'ont
pas l'habitude de le pratiquer je pense
notamment de toutes les nations
asiatiques qui ont plutôt des physiques
qui se rapprochent naturellement de
l'aviron poids léger c'était l'une des
courses passé la course dans laquelle
l'écart entre le premier et le 6e et le
plus faible sur tout les olympiades qui
sont courues donc ça donne des courses
assez spectaculaire qui sont après qui a
été apprécié tous les spectateurs donc
clairement je ne vois pas les arguments
logiques qui justifiait décision votre
objectif sera de ramener une médaille
maintenant
au prochain giro et même s'il ya eu ce
changement de catégorie ça ne change pas
vos plans ramener une médaille
encore une fois oui là on est encore
assez loin même très loin des prochains
jeux de tokyo donc c'est en 2020 on a le
temps de voir
on a le temps de travailler sur tout ce
qui est clair c'est qu'on continue pour
faire au moins aussi bien que à rio donc
donc d'aller chercher une médaille
maintenant voilà ça va pas être évident
il faudra aussi voir quelle est la
concurrence et quelles sont les forces
en présence et puis ensuite on pourra se
positionner plus clairement ses
décisions ne ratera pas à thomas baruch
en tout cas non j'ai quand il je compte
bien continuer donc encore quelques
années
merci beaucoup thomas barrau qui on va
faire chauffer la gomme dans ce set
sports pour parler de karting libinois
williams bertrand va disputer en 2010
est le tout nouveau championnat de
france juniors organisée par la
fédération française de sport automobile
cette compétition permettra de détecter
les futurs champions de l'hexagone les
meilleurs de la saison sont propulsés
vers les catégories de monoplace f4 en
2018 nous avons rencontré le prodige de
15 ans william bertrand pour lui poser à
trois questions
c'est un tout nouveau championnat le
championnat de france junior 2010 est
organisée par la ffsa academy donc c'est
sera sur cinq courses et ça permettra de
détecter les jeunes talents pour ensuite
les faire accéder à la monoplace f4 en
2018 c'est très important je n'ai qu'un
seul objectif pour ce championnat c'est
d'être titré champion de france et
pouvoir accéder à la f4 en 2018 et la f4
étant une catégorie monoplace une réelle
antichambre pour la f1 je suis très
confiant en plus je suis parmi les
favoris donc je pense ça va être un
championnat très intéressant et je joue
bien sûr aux avant postes
depuis mes débuts j'ai beaucoup
progressé sur le plan physique est aussi
personnel et la compétition m'a permis
de découvrir plein de choses et j'ai
beaucoup progressé et évolué sur le plan
sportif le plan personnel donc beaucoup
de domaines je dirais que j'ai pas
forcément de modèles car chacun son
pilotage
mais sinon parmi les meilleurs pilotes
il ya ce bassin de vettel schumacher
donc oui oui beaucoup de modèles mais
après chacun a sa personnalité et son
style de pilotage
c'est la fin de ses études sport merci
lundi prochain pour un nouveau magazine
d'ici là passez une excellente semaine
sportive très belle soirée sur tv fil 78
[Musique]